[Music]
and socialize for recovery news
submitted by phasma Oh summer bars are
popping up to help people in addiction
recovery stay social that's cute what's
sober bar it's a barber ball they've got
shelter or some people come and hang out
like a Jamba Juice look at my clothes I
think yes it's our vibe like a bar vibe
non alcoholic Heinekens that's a little
like doesn't that just make you want a
drink
that's mighty crazy the whole point is
like exposure therapy it's for people
who are recovering from being alcoholics
yeah so instead of just avoiding having
a night life or like ever going to to
anywhere at night where that might have
alcohol they go to these places and so
they get exposed like exposure to
triggers I don't think that's not work
so imagine you have a wife-beating habit
okay right yeah then they put you in a
room with all these chicks that just
talk about sex in the city or very
annoying women this part you are a sex
addict and they take you to a strip club
that sounds dumb and you kill you have a
book club meeting oh I mean the craziest
blue balls ever no you're just in the
strip club having a book club me oh but
there's oh I see so there's no strippers
you're in the environment but not and
there's no music exactly are the
strippers acting out the book I think
they should be with their bodies I think
the ones reading that's pretty good
workshopping it okay I don't know if
this works is all my friends that were
trying to quit smoking like back when
was like early twenties and stuff it's
the environment that made them go
[ __ ] you know what be so good I know a
cigarette right yes and the less the
more they end up smoking no it's like a
bunch of your NACA holic and you go your
bar you go to a bar in like the
nightlife everyone else having a good
time is a trigger for you yeah you just
like I want to also have a good time
but by being exposed to these kind of
bars you learn how to have a good time
without long hauls and there's
no no temptation available there Oh cuz
you can't even get it there see okay
yeah it's a reconditioning of that type
of behavior for my grandfather who was
an alcoholic like I think just just
opening his eyes some more things you
know for this one particular recovering
alcoholic of three years who's been
sober for three years she says that
she's like I can't do this alone like I
would need to have people that are
walking through with through this with
me and like for all of us to be a part
of something and just because like you
know I became sober to enjoy life and so
just because now I'm sober doesn't mean
I can't enjoy having one night like
pouring life go back to drinking back
you have to work so hard I mean I'm sure
I don't drink but if I could I would
it's really interesting that this this
whole group except for Kay seem to keep
teaching yeah yeah okay besides you
three doesn't really drink that much no
they don't yeah we're very fun do you
drink well never actually been to Yale
more lately we all kind of like found
each other like the other night um
because we've been having like angry
words for dinner and [ __ ] and I'm like
oh does it taste good with dinner seem
like drinking oh you get like did you
like 14 of them
no like Three's my max yeah that's not
drinking yeah but like I I mean it's
like the beginning of a beginning of a
perfect meet gargling mouthwash for more
than the recommended time he drinks like
once a week now what are you drinking do
you sure yeah what like what he has a
nice wine
he drinks this Thai beer he likes a lot
the one attempt to introduce me it's
really good chase Chong Jing Oh tanks I
love Chan that's really good my favorite
Thai place has $2 Chang's which is
[ __ ] oh yeah I don't know like I just
I would never drink as much as I took
now that's why I'm like this is weird
I've been slowly growing into it do you
like drinking um no but I'm starting to
enjoy like a glass of wine at dinner now
as opposed to before like I've never
really drink I feel like drinking is the
norm for people our age yeah everyone
drinks I think it's only a problem when
you go to the grocery store there's more
alcohol than your groceries yeah it's
like it's only a problem when you come
you're not planning for a party that's a
problem yeah yeah yeah I think it's only
a problem when you come home to beat
your wife yeah true
anything before that's fine yeah yeah if
you're drinking and driving yeah that's
that's a big problem too it's where I
feel like whenever I go cuz I don't
drink like I've spent so much time not
drinking whenever I go to a bar or
restaurant I don't know what to order
you know like if someone were to let me
buy you a drink what do you want like I
have no idea what that was me when I was
20 I was like what the [ __ ] do I do I
was like what's got tequila in it yeah
we always ask you what we should buy
right now I know what the [ __ ] to drink
yeah Moscow meals virgin pina coladas
other delicious vodka Red Bull or you
order like the thing that you only hear
on TV like can I get a cosmopolitan in
Long Island I see yeah you know like a
fuzzy navel that's the [ __ ] you hear on
TV do okay so I used to work at a bar as
a waitress right and then these kids
came in because we didn't really have
like a bar like a security guard was
early on and his kids came in who
clearly looked like they were like 16
years old right and for some reason like
they start ordering of course it's can I
have a Long Island iced tea a Cosmo can
I get him more like this is Shiva here
on TV how's it cool let me see some IDs
and all of them oh we left our IDs at
home how did you get in then you [ __ ]
well we didn't have a doorman because it
was so early and they can still ordered
no doorman yeah it wasn't like there was
a food we serve a adios [ __ ]
and then then they're like oh we got
and last time like no you don't just
check in once and you're good for the
rest of your [ __ ] life that's not how
it works and I'm the bad guy
Wow you know what's good you guys had
that truly [ __ ] yet or that white claw
I tried white cloth it's not that it's
like everyone keeps talking about is not
just like China Lacroix with it's like
degenerate little brother yeah it sucks
here so it's like a vodka soda line but
there's flavors to it yeah and you guys
like that I do you know why Bart
looks and trash the Cherokee Village
that I want to go to yeah what is it the
the cactus it's like a drug ayahuasca
thing when people that appear to find
themselves and it just sounds miserable
every time I hear about it like oh I
spent several hours throwing up in
hallucinating but I found myself you
know - same thing with alcohol you know
yeah and it's a different tree and I
just get a buzz for 45 minutes yeah but
alcohol is not a hallucinogen you see
yeah well you guys never heard of peyote
yeah it's cactus and it's a it's a it's
a psychedelic drug I never tried it but
I was like that's very nice mo get have
you done the other twinkle in your eye
''tis Lucinda Jim's I really like that
we could tell with the twinkle this
video by the way was about sobriety
don't drink don't drink or talk about
white clothes
I'm only fantasizing cuz I'm sober now I
get it you're sober very sober now yeah
yeah but you you had like so when I talk
about drugs I'm talking in retrospect
like this is 10 years ago but people
think it's fresh
alcohol also drink but you know what
it's like a in cell but with alcohol
right because I can't drink so if I
could I would so people think oh my god
yeah yeah in yeah involuntary soberness
so like people are like oh my god how do
you do it like so many people do like oh
you don't drink man that's so good like
I'm like it's not a choice full I just
don't like it
yeah it makes me feel nasty like I'll
drink I tried a you don't look at the oh
dude yeah at my birthday party my
cousins I feel like [ __ ] my cousins in
my aunt saw me drinking and then my
cousin came up to me she's like your
whole entire life you told us that you
were [ __ ] allergic what the hell it
works oh how come you didn't like it I
just don't like the taste it's good for
me it just makes me feel gross like I
get a headache you probably have the
same [ __ ] like I'm like why do people
enjoy this mm-hmm because it should feel
good drugs feel good alcohol makes me
junior recently though cuz our biology
changes well yeah I tried some gin and
tonic that without Jamie yeah but is
there like a lactate version for alcohol
oh people do the it's not benadryl is it
no it's like Sam attacker yeah but I
also started reading about it and
there's like article has say it's bad
for you Oh perhaps it yeah it perhaps it
Pepsodent alcohol like that combination
sells I don't know because it's not a
medication that's made specifically for
that it's just people found that it took
away the asianglow thing so it's like
imagine like you find another use for
Ajax or something you know but I don't
use it to clean the bathrooms I use it
to snort it and it [ __ ] you up too so I
don't know that's a good idea
please enjoy a couple weeks ago Nicky
was sick and I got her nyquil cuz she
asked me to get an eyeful but I got to
the [ __ ] syrup cuz that should
actually work and I was like they were
out of
so then she you know she took the baby
sometimes she's like I won't do it I
don't want to do it two girls two girls
she's Kira so then she then she she
actually took it she did the syrup thing
and she's like oh my god that was the
best night of sleep in my [ __ ] life
and actually why that addict is born I
call this [ __ ] good you know what
else is good Bera flu but they changed
their formula on the drink
mmm I can't wait to be sick sometimes
I'm like that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up whole
entire body yep
so kind of made me curious like what is
what is it like they're like are people
really having like the time of their
lives
why not they're probably doing what
we're doing is just talking about how
good alcohol is while they're drinking
[ __ ] non-alcoholic drinks oh that
[ __ ] white clavo both angry orchard
both oh yeah coffee
I've never been to a bar during the day
like from a YouTube shoot or anything no
cuz for YouTube shoots I've done that a
bunch I'd like for other couple are that
like a VidCon or a playlist live like
that well not but like you're at a bar
shooting it but you we pretend like yeah
bet it's like that what me going to a
place like this is just normal life for
me it's amazing that you stayed sober in
Vietnam every person that gets off the
plane gets a free bottle of Hennessy did
you get a hang no one offered you any
obey Jesus I just got slacking off the
plane huh
nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]